If you choose to be the kind of artist
that stands for something,
that you want to be yourself
and bring yourself into everything that you do,
you will get fewer parts,
you will.
The parts you get
will move you
in a way that most artists will not get moved.
Or
you can bend and manipulate yourself a little bit
and sort of be a little bit more of what they want
and play their role
and even though you don't really buy into it
it's a part and I want to be an actor
I want to be a performer
I'm gonna do what they want.
You will absolutely get more parts
without a doubt.
You will arguably have a "better career"
but will you be profoundly moved as an artist?
The odds are lower.
I can't say never,
it's just the odds are lower.
It's not better or worse.
It is simply the decision on how you choose
to manage or lead your own career.